in the current technological era coming
across different computer problems
related to malware and cyber tax is
common
according to av test institute there are
more than one billion malware programs
available
and new malware programs are detected
regularly
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn but
before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
in this video we'll understand what is a
malware program
then we'll see what exactly are viruses
and trojans
then we will see how they operate in a
system
and then different types of viruses and
trojan
and how to detect the activity of such
programs
and lastly we will see how to prevent
our system from getting infected by such
programs
malware is a malicious software that is
programmed to cause damage to a computer
system network and hardware devices
many malicious programs like trojan
viruses worms and bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user
or to steal money from the target by
stealing sensitive data
let's take a look at the introduction
for two different types of malware virus
and trojan
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself
they get attached to different files and
programs which are termed as host
programs by inserting their code if the
attachment succeeds the targeted program
is termed as infected with a computer
virus
now let's take a look at the trojan
horse
trojan horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into a
system to allow the cyber criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into our system
firstly we have virus programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a surge routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
trojan horse functioning
for trojan horses entryway into our
system is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the trojan
program gets installed and infects the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file and attacks the system
now that we understand what virus and
trojans are let's understand different
types of virus androgens
let's take a look at different types of
viruses
the first one is known as the booth
sector virus this type of virus damages
the booting section of the system by
infecting the master bot record which is
also known as mbr
this damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
then we have the macro virus
micro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is opened
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
trojans
the first type of trojan is the backdoor
trojan
they are designed to create a backdoor
in the system on execution of an
infected program
they provide remote access of our system
to the hacker this way the cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
quick source trojan
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they attempt a user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the cyber criminal
and the last trojan type is ransom
trojan
this type of trojan program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing
its own system and also affects the
system functioning
the cyber criminal demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
trojan program from the device
now that we understand some details
regarding viruses and trojan let's solve
a question
the question is jake was denied access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in his
system
now
the actual question is what could be the
reason behind his system's problem
option a macro virus option b ransom
trojan option c backward version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and trojan in our
system
to detect virus or trojan activity in a
system we can refer to the following
points
for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
account details
which may lead to unexpected log out
from the accounts or corruption of the
sensitive data
and lastly we have frequent system
crashes due to virus infection which
damages the operating system
for trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate trojan activity
and lastly we have modification in the
system application and change of the
desktop appearance can be also due to
the infection of a trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous cyber
attack for virus and a trojan horse
for virus we have
the my doom virus which was identified
in the er 2004 which affected over 50
million systems by creating a network of
sending spam emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the trojan horse we have the
emote trojan program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
viruses can
this will prevent virus entry in the
system and also having more than one
antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into our
system
then we have
using regular driver updates and system
updates to prevent virus entry for
trojan we have using certified softwares
from legal sites to prevent any trojan
activity in our system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against trojan horses is
a good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video let's take a look what we learnt
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the trojan we have stealing of the
data files and information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas trojan
horses are remote accessed
and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
trojan does not have the
replication ability
if you have any questions you can ask
them on the comment section thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here